what am i most excited about for this
year
that's super easy i'm excited to have
everyone back together and in person and
we've been waiting for this for 18
months and today's the first day when
the mba students are back and it's
finally arrived and it feels great
i told the mba class that they're
arriving at a great time
and of course part of that is they're
arriving and we're starting to get
toward the end of the pandemic and so
the world is opening up and stanford is
opening up and all the things that we've
been looking forward to we can start to
do again together
they're arriving at a time when there's
incredible change going on in the world
in technology in business and in society
and they're arriving at stamford at a
time when they can be right in the
middle of all of that change and
thinking about what it is they want to
do with their careers and lives
i think there's two big lessons from the
experience going through the pandemic
and teaching and interacting online
one was a positive which was it was sort
of a revelation what you could do
virtually in terms of getting work done
and having classes and keeping even a
place like stamford running
the other was
there's just a set of things that happen
at a business school at a university
that you can't replicate with technology
and if you think back before the
pandemic
in the case of mba programs people were
actually questioning is there value in a
residential mba program i think the
pandemic just definitively answered that
question in a positive way yes there's
just something about being with a group
of people
students and with faculty and with the
mix of people that comes onto campus
and just being in it that
we still can't do with technology and we
can do it here on a place like the gsb
campus
[Music]
my go-to drink or order at koopa oh it's
so boring it's just a small black coffee
[Music]
i've been running a lot up in the
foothills and
every time i get out in the california
foothills it just reminds me why i moved
out to california in the first place and
why i have never left this place
[Music]
you